hey what's up guys in kabhi AC here and
we finally have it the hype is finally
through we have the specs and the design
and everything of the oneplus 2
officially official to the 5.5 inch
display the 3300 milliamp hour battery
the 13 megapixel camera the Snapdragon
810 4 gigabytes of RAM and USB type-c
all in a pretty premium metal build that
fits in the footprint of its predecessor
so I was in the unique position of
actually being able to use a oneplus 2
for the past couple weeks two weeks or
so before launch which I guess looking
at other articles and stuff not a lot of
other people have had that so while I'm
not about to drop a full on review video
for you guys right now I do have a bunch
of impressions after using this guy on
and off for the past couple of weeks so
these are five impressions I have of the
oneplus 2 first off dat button I kind of
dig it and when we heard that the
oneplus 2 would have a fingerprint
reader right there were some speculation
about where it might be some thought it
might be on the back of the phone some
phones have it on the side but like the
iPhone 6 and the galaxy s6 the oneplus 2
also puts it on the middle right on the
home button which i think is the most
convenient place to put it for using a
fingerprint sensor you can use it
without flipping the phone over to the
back and it's not crazy hard to reach to
unlock your phone the oneplus 2
fingerprint reader however is not like
the galaxy s6 and it's not like the
iphone 6 in the fact that it's not a
physical pressing button it doesn't
actually press down or click like other
phones it's actually more of a touchpad
that doesn't move like we saw on the HTC
One m9 plus it still acts in the same
way as a regular home button though so
tapping it from anywhere brings you home
and you can assign a specific action to
a long press or a double tap of actually
any of the bottom buttons so the default
of the home button long press is to open
Google now which I like and also I'm a
double tapping the home button a camera
shortcut just like the galaxy s6 but you
can do whatever else you want in the
software which is dope and of course you
can also just hold down on the unlock
screen to unlock the phone with your
fingerprint and accuracy for me has been
north of 90 percent I'd say it's pretty
accurate and pretty quick I only have
one registered finger but that's all I
need is just one thumb and you can also
hold down your registered finger on the
home button when the display is off to
get it to wake the phone and just
into the UI so it reads your finger
pretty fast and is ready to go I really
like this feature also for those worried
about the off-screen buttons first of
all the left capacitive button is the
back button by default and the right
button is the multitasking carousel but
you can switch them if you want to have
it match other phones or disable them
completely and just use on-screen
buttons for those who are all about that
Nexus feel so my impression number two
is on battery life now again my last two
weeks have been spent with a pre-release
model so while it does appear pretty
much identical to the final version
things could still change by the time
the final version ships to you guys but
here's my experience battery life on the
oneplus 2 is pretty good now what was my
benchmark I was using a galaxy s6 edge
alongside it for the past couple weeks
so I guess it doesn't take a whole lot
to impress me but really though for all
the hoopla about the Snapdragon 810
going with a 1080p display while it may
disappoint some members of team crispy
is actually a really good move for the
battery life Department standby time is
really good and it lasted two days
standby without a problem if I didn't
use it much and during actually use I'm
getting about four and a half hours of
screen on time but again remember what I
said this could change I ran a benchmark
just for kicks since I had the time and
we all know the oneplus one was a freak
with battery life Geekbench gave that a
battery score of 3606 with 6 hours of
screen on time and it gave the oneplus 2
a battery score of 2871 with less than 5
hours of screen on time yeah b-minus for
now impression number three is on USB
type-c this is either one of the first
or the first smartphones launching with
a USB type-c port and if you're curious
about what all this means you can watch
the entire full-on explainer video I did
about this new port I'll leave it linked
right below bottom line here is it's not
in microUSB anymore so you will need a
new charger and obviously oneplus will
ship you a charging cable I ended up
actually using my Chromebook pixel
charger because it's longer cable and
it's still USB type-c and that also
means no quick charging here so it took
about three hours to charge up from 25%
to full and I guess I was a little bit
spoiled by the galaxy s6 battery
obviously it's a smaller battery but
it's also quick charge 2.0 and that
thing charges like crazy fast so I got
used to that so I guess the combination
of a larger battery and a lack of quick
charge from USB type-c made it feel even
with the chromebook pixel charger kind
of like a slow trickle but then again it
shouldn't be that big of a deal if I'm
only charging it once a day if it's
lasting longer than the galaxy s6 and
believe me it is lasting longer on
battery in the galaxy s6 fourth
impression is specifically on the
thermals there been plenty of people
wondering about the Snapdragon 810 does
it get hot does it overheat is it going
to burn me does this thing have thermal
problems well so far
nope the one thing the closest thing I
can say about that is that it does get
warm to the touch after using it for a
long time or gaming for a while which is
pretty normal and but it's never
actually gotten so hot or gotten to the
point where it's limited performance or
functionality in any sort of noticeable
way I don't know if you remember when I
did my super early first impressions of
the LG g3 what actually did do that
after a certain point after a bunch of
gaming it would say listen it's gotten
too hot we're gonna limit your
brightness because it needs to cool down
but no such problems with my oneplus 2
in fact I think my Galaxy s6 has
probably gotten just as warm to the
touch
especially after a lot of gaming right
along these metal rails but neither of
them has actually had any problems just
for kicks here's a thermal image of the
galaxy s6 edge up top and the oneplus 2
on the bottom after some light gaming
after about 5 minutes the oneplus 2 here
is 2 degrees Fahrenheit warmer on the
back by the camera again neither have
any problems and then after some heavy
gaming for about half an hour here's the
oneplus 2 definitely very warm to the
touch
but as far as I could tell no difference
in performance or function finally
impression number 5 is that the whole
software experience is very clean it's
it's oxygen OS version 2 it's a super
close to stock Android experience but
with some added features kind of like
CyanogenMod first of all the custom
button on the side of the phone is
awesome it acts as a quick switch
between showing all notifications prior
any mode or do not disturb mode and I
use this at least once a day and then
there are also some other nice features
like the ability to rearrange the icons
and the quick settings and save that
there's also a toggle to enable a
system-wide dark theme which looks
pretty nice it basically reverses the
colors in a guest like the Settings app
and uses cyan accents you can go into
app permissions also kind of like
Android M and revoke certain permissions
from apps that don't seem to need it
even though this isn't a rom based on
Android M this is a cool feature to see
and there's a couple of other things too
of course I've done an entire video just
on oxygen OS
bakwin version 1.0 came out for the 1+1
so if you want to check that out see
what it's all about I'll leave a link to
that video right below that like button
and those are my early impressions so if
your clamoring for more oneplus stuff
definitely check out my camera review
which I did specifically all about the
oneplus 2 use camera and comparing it to
other flagships and stuff and that's
essentially it if you follow me on
Twitter they get more impressions and
stuff as I build up all my stuff for the
full review so subscribe to be among the
first to see that and that's basically
it
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one bass